alors le coup de coeur du cinéma les
yeux d'elsa cette semaine il s'agit du
film skaff holding qui sortira le 18
mars prochain sous le titre les destiner
d'achères et donc vous l'avez compris ce
qu une avant première c'est une avant
première d'un film qui a été repéré par
l'acide qui est l' agence du cinéma
indépendant pour sa diffusion
c'est un collectif de cinéastes qui
repèrent des films qui les amène à
cannes et qui nous propose de les re
découvrir en salles et du coup pour
accompagner ce film qui du coup est
quasiment inconnu mais qui est un grand
film vraiment un très très beau film on
a aura le plaisir d'accueillir le
réalisateur de ce film
matagne haïr qui est israélien et qui
viendra donc échanger avec vous sur son
film sa manière de faire du cinéma
comment il a rencontré cet acteur que
vous allez pouvoir découvrir dans ce
film qui est vraiment un acteur
exceptionnel s'agit de l'histoire d'un
jeune homme qui va être pris entre son
père qui souhaite qu'il reprenne
l'entreprise d'échafaudages familiale et
puis sa découverte tout à coup d'un d'un
jeu d'un professeur de littérature qui
va l'ouvrir au monde
et puis évidemment il ya un retournement
de situation dont je ne vous dis rien
qui va bouleverser tout ce petit
équilibre
donc je vous invite à venir le samedi 23
septembre à 20h30 pour découvrir ce film
ait rencontré son réalisateur matagne à
lire au cinéma les yeux d'elsa
à très bientôt